a pleasure to talk with you this morning
about something up and working on for
about 20 years see as the governor said
last night and as David Alvarez said
yesterday morning Puerto Rico is far
along in privatizing through a long-term
lease the San Juan International Airport
that I presume all of us arrived at a
pretty shabby airport a couple years ago
Lou and I changed planes at San Juan
internationals first time I'd ever been
here and we spent about two and a half
hours in these really shabby
surroundings with practically nothing
useful to buy or good food or anything
that I am confident will all change once
once the privatization gets implement
you can see they pre-qualified six
global world-class teams they are
preparing their bids and they'll be
submitted within the next month or so
and probably bye-bye spring this they
will announce the winner and then the
process will go forward they will
finance the acquisition and start
transforming the airport into a
world-class facility that that it really
should be now as as man he mentioned
Margaret Thatcher during her three terms
in office privatized the commanding
heights of government owned enterprises
in the UK this included privatizing
british airways british gas british
telecom british coal a british petroleum
and also British airports authority
which became baa plc and turned into
very of world-class airport operator and
yet here in the United States we still
have everywhere government strictly
government-owned airports and you might
wonder why is this how the land of free
enterprise how did this turn out to be
what we're saddled with well government
airports in the United States basically
started out as municipal enterprises but
they were considered an infant industry
that couldn't be self-supporting every
city wanted you know
the new thing to have planes flying to
your city so it quickly became an idea
that they needed to be supported by
taxpayers and in addition United States
is relatively unique for public sector
agencies to be able to issue tax-exempt
bonds most of the world that's not the
case and so that gave an additional
advantage those who talked about doing
airports privately would have had to
issue for large capital projects taxable
bonds most of the time there's a
significant interest rate differential
which means it's a lot more expensive to
issue taxable bonds than tax-exempt
bonds so that was another thing that
locked in place this early model and
prevented it from changing in addition
of the airport the city airport
departments or authorities were very
skittish in the early days of airlines
even after World War two in the 50s
about well what if the airline's they're
serving us now but maybe they'll go away
and we'll be stuck with the bonds that
we have to pay off so they locked the
airline's into long-term agreements that
you know committed them for 25 or 30
years to be serving the airport and
paying space rentals and so forth to pay
off the bonds but it the airline's
extracted a price for that as anchor
tenants in terms of gaining a lot of
control over what happened at the
airports and you know this this
environment was not too bad prior to
airline deregulation in 1978 because it
was a pretty static industry then things
didn't change very rapidly the same
airline served the same airports for a
long period of time because they to
serve something else they would have to
go before the Civil Aeronautics Board
and make all kinds of prove that there
was a need for a new service and so far
so it was hardly anything that you would
call a dynamic industry so we have these
we have a bad situation with airport
than developed over all these things we
got Airlines the incumbent Airlines got
veto power over new entrance which made
it very very hard for upstarts like
Southwest Airlines to get into airports
that were dominated by what we now call
the legacy carriers
we ended up with in many cases like at
JFK and at LAX airline dominated
terminals where one Airport controlled a
whole whole terminal or concourse at an
airport and had monopoly control of the
gates we have an inefficient nonprofit
model that that was not at all what what
it could be in an error in an industry
that turned out to especially after
deregulation could have to be very
dynamic and fast changing industry and
way grading way back into the 50s we had
a system of airport federal grants to
airports that also ended up imposing
significant economic regulation on the
airports because as a condition of
getting the federal grants the airports
have to agree to all kinds of conditions
that they wouldn't take any money from
the airport and put it into the city
budget it has to stay there and build up
facilities on the air this is Airlines
insisted on that so and we also this
that meant that when you have congestion
at certain airports like the New York
airports in Chicago you would think well
you know obviously if you charge higher
prices during the busy periods airlines
would have an incentive to use bigger
planes or shift some flights to lower
demand times not possible because
there's no runway pricing under this
kind of static model so while all this
is saying staying the status quo the
United States in much of the rest of the
world inspired by Mark Margaret Thatcher
did in the UK and seeing the results of
much better airports from from the
privatized model we're seeing airports
haven't been rican ception alized as
business enterprises as in fact
for-profit business enterprises in
basically all of Europe in Australia and
in parts of Asia even in parts of Latin
America so as a business enterprise the
airport has control of all the
facilities and can make efficient use of
them you don't have gates being empty
part of the day because an airline had
locked in exclusive use and keeps
everybody else out pro profit effort
company wants to maximize the use of all
these expensive resources and so it
controls all of them put it puts in
common
is facilities that can be shared in fact
some US efforts have actually started
doing that now because it's so efficient
if you go into an airport and you see
that the signage at your gate is only
electronic that's probably a clue that
it's a common use gate now and it's
shared among different airline because
the airport has managed to regain
control over time of its resources
copying the model that they see overseas
of for-profit and privatized airports
these these profit-making airports
overseas even if they haven't been
privatized as many of them have their
they're still corporatized they're
actually incorporated under corporate
law and they're expected to pay taxes
like any other corporation even if the
government is the sole shareholder they
still there they're a business
enterprise and they pay taxes and but
but wait we have seen over the last two
decades over a hundred major airports
have been privatized and that's true all
over Europe with a few exceptions it's
true in a significant part of Latin
America it's true in Australia and New
Zealand and you know some other parts of
growing Southeast Asia three different
models the sale which is the way
Margaret Thatcher did at a public stock
offering of the whole enterprise and
most of the privatization in Europe is
by sale either of all of the airport or
of a significant part you have still
partial government ownership say of
Frankfurt and Vienna but in many cases
that's becoming majority private sector
ownership Madrid and Barcelona are on
the way to being privatized by the the
cash-strapped Spanish government then
the second model is a long-term lease or
concession which is what Puerto Rico is
about to do this is true in of the major
Australian airports it's also the main
model in Latin America Argentina a
santiago airport in chile and about to
happen with the major brazilian airports
that's underway now probably i think
next month the first three major
Brazilian airports the competition is
underway they'll announce the winning
bidders and then for the smaller
developing countries more developing
countries in Latin America and the
Caribbean the model has been
mostly to build new terminals with
private investment on a long-term
build-operate-transfer contract these
are typically maybe 30 years long and
the Montego Bay Airport that I did the
initial feasibility study for in the
1990s was privatized under the build
operate transfer model so all of this
has been going on while the United
States has been mostly oblivious during
the last two decades who's investing in
airports well you saw on the list of the
bidders for San Juan global
infrastructure funds of which there's
now several hundred of these funds have
been in these are equity investment
funds that would make that essentially
the down payment and then would raise
debt capital to finance the rest of the
acquisition of an airport pension funds
have been starting to get into this
australian and canadian pension funds
have been the global leaders in this and
but in the last couple of years us
pension funds such as the giant calpers
in California have started setting aside
a portion of their portfolios for
alternative investments including
infrastructure and the only
infrastructure that makes sense for them
as nonprofits to invest in is for profit
a privately owned infrastructure so
CalPERS would made an investment in
gatwick airport last year and they now
own almost thirteen percent of it the
ontario teachers pension plans these
canadian ones are just amazing they're
mostly public sector pension funds like
like CalPERS but they're investing in
privatized infrastructure which is kind
of an interesting ironic twist and then
of course debt providers the bond
markets are and banks are big players in
all of this too so there's already the
capital is out there wanting to invest
in in vibrant enterprises than in a
growth industry like like aviation in
the United States this has only happened
really so far in niche markets we have
management contracts a few new terminals
handful of specialized new airports and
then leases under the pilot program
which I'll talk about so management
contracts if you've ever flown into
Burbank or Albany you may not have
realized that those were privately man
under short term management contracts
and there's a small industry that that
does that that's quietly been going on
for several decades and that's not
really what we think about as
privatization in the global sense which
is transfer of ownership but an
investment but so that's that's the
small niche market we also have a couple
of cases jfk's terminal 4 and the
orlando sanford airport which is the
secondary airport and orlando that
mostly serves european charter airlines
both of these terminals had been
developed on this build operate transfer
model where private investment has come
in they build it operated management for
the period of time of the things so
that's another little niche that's out
there and then we have to greenfield
brand new airports one to serve Branson
Missouri a country music capital and the
other one is still trying to get off the
ground as a third Chicago Airport and
that's but it's been a project in trying
to come into existence for about the
past 10 years and Branson has been in
operation so far it's kind of shaky it's
gets attracted some airline service but
they're not actually meeting their debt
service and so it may or may not really
survive in the current form but again
that's another tiny little niche but
then I helped reason foundation worked
with governor then governor Pataki of
New York to bring about in 1996 a
federal pilot program now why would you
need a pilot program well because under
these grant regulations that airports
have all accepted because they get
federal money there's no way that if you
get have those grants that you can make
a profit you can't if you if you sell or
lease your Airport you can't take the
proceeds into your city budget because
all the money must by law remain in the
airport so why would anybody privatize
if under those know the company wouldn't
do it because they can't make a profit
the city wouldn't do it because they
can't take the proceeds so the pilot
program provides exemptions from those
regulations for five airports and it
permits this to happen
it has had a slow troubled history only
five airports you know other
restrictions and the worst part is that
last one because the airlines were
scared to death of this because they
didn't want to lose the remaining
control that they had over keeping out
competitors and stuff the airline's
lobbied for in God a supermajority
requirement they have to approve the
terms of a deal or it or it can't happen
the city can't take any of the proceeds
and so forth so that has been a big
obstacle for the most part for more than
4 15 years and we we only had one tiny
transaction done in New York State of
the stewart airport north of New York
City was privatized but the airline's
didn't approve that so New York State
was not allowed to use the proceeds for
the general state budget the only thing
they could do was invested in there they
have several other state-owned airports
so they got republic Field on Long
Island put some of the money to that
they could actually prove Stewart and
the company that least it only lasted
five years and they were British company
they thought they were going to be a big
market in the u.s. of airport private up
they thought is way too hard and they
decided to go back to their main
business which was was bus and rail
transport mostly in Europe and so they
they sold their lease to the Port
Authority of New York New Jersey so went
back into into government control but in
the last five years there's been a
rebirth of interest in the in the
federal pilot program Chicago had a deal
they got a selected a winning bidder in
2008 yes and the deal was actually the
company that when the bid bid two and a
half billion dollars it was too much and
it right they can they had to try to
finance the deal right as the credit
crunch happened and people said this is
way to leverage way too risky a deal and
they couldn't finance it so it collapsed
but the good part about the Midway deal
was that the airline's actually approved
that deal it met the sixty-five percent
approval requirement and that changed
the whole ballgame all of a sudden
people said oh I guess this thing is
going to be real after all if major
airlines could come to an agreement and
so now
San Juan is proceeding under the pilot
program the airlines have approved it 60
got the sixty-five percent and now four
of the five slots in the pilot program
have candidates that have applied and
been given the slots and interesting
life Rahm Emanuel as as mayor of Chicago
when he was campaigning he said I was a
terrible idea weirdo Widow I won't do
this once he got into office had to face
the budget problems of Chicago they read
back to the FAA said can we please hang
on to our slot for another year and
because we really would need to look at
this more carefully so I've expect once
san one assuming san juan gets a good
deal and closes that transaction Chicago
will be back in being asking for bids
and and going ahead with Midway and so
what I'm thinking I strongly predict
that the San Juans success which I think
will happen will lead to a new burst of
interest and in fact the FAA
reauthorization bill that was agreed to
by the conference committee this past
week accepted the house provision to
increase the number of slots from five
to ten we were hoping to get rid of the
cap on slots and just mainstream the
program that didn't happen we also the
House bill called for removing the
airline approval requirement the Senate
wouldn't go along with that so we still
have the airline approval requirement
but at least we have ten slots instead
of five so I a new era of airport
privatization is about to dawn now does
this matter well yes there's actually
beginning there's a fair amount of good
empirical studies that shows that when
airports are probably you compare us a
sample and now we have over a hundred
privatized airports worldwide compare a
sample of privatized airports to a
similar set of non privatized airports
they're significantly better in a whole
lot of ways one is passenger
friendliness measured by an index of a
whole bunch of things others increased
operating efficiency more aggressive
marketing more robust revenue and so
forth so I mean it really does work just
as we expected at work the second thing
that's happening now in parallel with
the impending rebirth of serious airport
privatization activity in the United
States is something called airline
deregulation this has just pop
duck in the last maybe six or eight
months the airline the airports in the
United States represented by airports
council international are getting so fed
up with Congress and the constraints
that they have to operate under with the
economic regulation imposed by the grant
agreements and with Congress's refusal
to allow the airports to do more self
financing through something called the
passenger facility charge that they have
started lobbying for deregulation then
they called the moses initiative let my
airports go and a number of the leading
airports have signed things petitioning
congress they petitioned the of the
deficit reduction Commission that failed
to come up you know the supercommittee
they wanted in exchange for giving up
federal grants to get out from under
this restriction on their own ability to
have local charges against which they
can issue bonds and so forth and you
know they haven't achieved that yet but
this is a sea change I never thought I
would see that happen and this Airport
organization is regularly talking with
with me with Reason Foundation they see
us as a key ally it trying to build
support and explain the case for for
doing these sorts of thing and that is a
very important step forward that
compliments of the airport privatization
effort and means we have a much better
chance of developing truly market-driven
airports in the United States which will
be better for all of us who fly the
passenger facility charge I mean this is
an issue we can probably since we don't
have much time get into more in the
question period but the short thing on
this is PFC it was legalized legalized
in 1990 by Congress prior to that it was
completely illegal thanks to airline
lobbying for the it for any Airport the
United States to charge a per passenger
fee a local fee that would solely to
improve the infrastructure to build a
better terminal to have more space for
planes and so on and so forth the
airline said oh no we want the airports
to be dependent solely on federal grants
with all the controls that go along with
it that that we're favorable to airlines
so Congress defied the airline's
legalized PFC
b-but they limited it to his maximum
three dollars in 1990 it was increased a
beginning of the 2000s two for maximum
of four or 50 turns out the bond markets
love this they'll issue revenue bonds
backed by the PFC revenues almost every
Airport in the United States charges a
PFC now but the airline's every time the
airport say well you know is about of
inflation we should have a higher charge
with all these unfunded projects the
airline's say oh no this would be a
federal tax increase you know it's not a
federal tax it's only the cap that the
amount that Congress allows them to
charge it's entirely a local option
local self help but who bah who accepts
this airline propaganda groped my friend
Grover Norquist accepts that the
National Taxpayers Union accept that and
parrots the airline propaganda and
convinces the fiscal conservatives in
Congress to oppose this because it would
be a big federal tax increase its
absolute BS and that's why the year
airport groups loves us because we say
no no this is exactly the kind of
devolution getting out from under the
federal controls in the federal grants
that you fiscal conservatives are always
talking about so you know you're you're
you're talking out of both sides of your
mouth on this by by buying into the
phony airline propaganda and so this is
a fight that is still going to go on the
FAA reauthorization bill ignored the
whole PFC issue so we're now stuck with
four more years of the status quo where
the airports are hampered in the ability
to do more self financing the project
because of that ridiculous propaganda I
am proposing as a sort of a stealth
measure to lead to more privatization
corporatization of airports this would
follow the European model where the
airports would the city government or
county government that owns an airport
would incorporate it under the state
corporation law to make it a business
enterprise it would be expected to make
a profit the city or the county would be
initially the sole shareholder and but
it would it would be an important change
in the in the business philosophy the
conceptualization of what the airport it
was supposed to be
in principle it could go on the local
property tax rolls a huge piece of
property would be expected to as if it
makes a profit to pay taxes just like
the European airports do and this could
be a way of getting serious d
federalization in exchange for the
status of becoming truly a
self-supporting business enterprise you
would have to deal with the consumer
protection most airports are monopolies
if it became a business it would become
subject to the antitrust laws you know
where I'm not a fan of antitrust laws
but one business shouldn't be exempted
when all the others are they should
exist like normal businesses and I
actually have proposed a kind of
light-handed approach to dealing to
consumer protection where you simply
have the antitrust laws apply and then
do a couple of structural things to
prohibit the airlines from from owning
buying control of airports because that
would really be a conflict of interest
and possibly break up monopolies shared
monopolies like the port authority of
new york and new jersey owning Newark
LaGuardia and Kennedy and making those
airports allowing those airports to
compete under under separate ownership
and then here's here's the sneaky thing
once the city has incorporated
for-profit airport it would be not that
big of a step then to as in Germany as
in Italy to have the city safe mm-hmm we
need we need to build new terminals we
could sell a share of equity through a
public stock offering we could sell it
to our residence we could sell it to a
strategic investor like like one of the
global airport companies or we could
have a general nationwide IPO of shares
in LAX and I knew this would this I
think would be a non frightening way for
the people that now own and order now
operate airports to see they'd be in
control of the privatization it wouldn't
be something coming in from outside
taking it over and fun they would fear
firing everybody but be something driven
locally that that they would be able to
do it anyway I think I think this is a
model that has not been proposed
not been suggesting United States before
but actually has a lot of potential for
going somewhere final final point this
is exactly the right time in in the
course of the fiscal situation of
governments of the United States to
consider these kinds of changes to how
we govern and manage important
infrastructure and this applies not only
airports but to highways and seaports
and other things the federal budget for
the rest of our lives for generations is
going to be hugely constrained in what
it can do the idea that there's going to
be federal grants for anything under the
Sun is laughable it's ridiculous and so
but infrastructure is very important
it's it's the last thing we want to be
cutting back on through arbitrary
cutbacks in federal government support
so the challenge before us if we if we
believe infrastructure is important is
to liberate it from the federal
government it make it enable all
infrastructure to be self-supporting
from its own revenue this would include
things like the interstate highway
system airports seaports getting off of
the federal dole get them out from under
federal control and make them truly
self-supporting as business enterprises
from from charges that users pay and
make them market driven and turns out
the simpson-bowles Commission that that
Obama appointed and which came out with
this whole agenda of how we could start
fixing the federal government's project
one of their little notice
recommendations was exactly something
along those lines that all this
infrastructure that has been getting
federal aid the can't afford to do that
anymore in this new fiscal climate but
we need to protect it by by raising the
level of user fees and user types
getting it off the federal dole making
self-supporting so this is a challenge
that that reason foundation will be
taking on across the board for all
infrastructure in the United States save
it from from from the wreck of the fist
of the federal government by making it
self-supporting and and I think there's
a pathway that we can really make a
difference in doing that and with that
until Amy gives me the hook we'll have
questions thank you
excuse themselves because you need to be
downstairs yeah you get me for questions
after at dinnertime what about security
that is that if this takes hold that
that then over time have the airlines
it's their responsibility then what your
planes going down i know i think the
responsibility for security should be
devolved to the airport not the airlines
the problem with the airline's doing it
was the airline's compete with one
another and and the cost of the security
that they have to provide I think was a
problem they wanted to minimize that
cost and they ended up with cheap
rent-a-cops that that you know there
were no standards for so the model that
we've been promoting and it was in the
New York Times article on Monday by
Susan sellin is to devolve the
responsibility to the airport level
allow the airports to either make or buy
higher security staff themselves that
meet federal standards or hire a
federally certified security company
that has the proper standards and
training requirements and so forth and I
think most airports will do the ladder
they'll do the security which is the way
it works in most of Europe if you go to
London go to Frankfurt these are
outsourced security all of Canada does
outsource private security companies
that are certified and federally
overseen nobody but the United States
created a security agency that is both
the regulator and the provider of
airport screening that's a terrible
model and I think we're starting to gain
traction for what we've been
recommending and thank you very much
John for the question early on in the
slide yet some comment about noise and
privatization would help with that yes
is a bit of a controversy as I
understand in charlotte north carolina
side be interested in your comments yea
noise is a very big constraint on the
growth that's needed the expansion of
airport the united states and i think
there's a connection that I see between
privatization and dealing with noise is
that privatization produces a much more
robust economic enterprise that can
afford in its own interest to do things
like buying out neighborhoods and paying
you know really in a fair reasonable
compensation it can buy noise easements
and or can buy out neighborhoods and
both models have been used it's not been
used very aggressively United States
Frankfurt Airport freeport is the
privatized company that now owns and
operates Frankfurt Airport they added a
I think it's the fifth runway that
opened last year it was an industrial
site that was adjacent to Frankfurt
Airport they negotiated with a major
German chemical company that had a plan
on the site the complete by out of that
price they were able to do that because
of the robust economic model that
privatization has produced they could
afford and it really makes sense from a
business proposition a fifth runway
makes an enormous difference for
Frankfurt to continue to grow as a major
hub in competition with Heathrow with
Charles de Gaulle in Paris and with
schiphol in Amsterdam so they secured
their position for the future by seeing
the business case to spend a fortune
buying out that large industrial thing
and building this this fifth runway so
that's the connection a question I'm
flying into a lot of small airports
where there may only be one or two
commercial flights where they're more
TSA agents and passenger ahead to me
it's ludicrous and obviously couldn't be
privatized how do you think that'll
that'll play out in the future this is a
good question and and the sad news on
this very small airports is that this
egregious federal subsidy program called
essential air services EAS which the
house trust started out trying to reform
and that caused the whole controversy
that shut down the FAA in August a house
Cape threw in the towel on that in the
the reauthorization bill that they
agreed to this week completely guts the
reform EIS will continue in the present
form even cutting off the the most
egregious ones putting in a cap on the
amount of subsidy per passenger ely
nevada three or four hundred
or spur all got included and continued
it's a complete disaster so for the next
four years there's going to be no change
whatever in that reason foundation was
part of a study that came out intended
to try to help with that that analyzed
the provision of intercity bus service
to a lot of those airports showed that
many of them are within 100 miles of
airport without subsidized service that
would be way way more cost effective in
many cases would you wouldn't need any
subsidy because the verses would be
willing to do it to provide scheduled
bus service to those airports with
unsubsidized airports are so that's
really a much better longer-term answer
Bob I understand sir air traffic control
system is also federally run and
extremely out of date if we would
actually update it the density of
airplanes in the air could safely be
increased immensely yes occur and have a
huge impact also of course on
provocative productivity of the
airport's themselves is there any
pathway to getting modernization in that
area now there is we're working very
very hard below the radar so to speak on
that issue I've been working on that
ever since the controller strike in
nineteen eighty one when the Reagan
administration flew me to Washington to
give briefings on a privatization
approach which the FAA Administrator the
time absolutely vetoed and was the end
of that but the good news is that since
New Zealand corporatized its air traffic
control system in nineteen i think was
nineteen eighty seven fifty countries
have turned their aircraft control says
they've taken it out of the government
Aviation agency made it a
self-supporting business enterprise a
few of them are private most of them are
government corporations but they run on
a for-profit business basis entirely a
hundred percent supported by user fees
paid by the users of the air system they
have successfully consolidated their
facilities to save a lot of money they
run efficient they've been modernizing
putting the new technology in ways that
are simply not possible for the
FAA to do it's definitely something that
should happen in the United States I do
a monthly air traffic control reform
newsletter which you can subscribe to
for free if you just send me an email
and we have a project underway with a
top-notch team of people that again is
completely under the radar and John you
can't you can't broadcast anything about
this but we are we're going to be
quietly briefing each of the major
aviation groups this spring on the plan
that we've come up with the the airport
trade associations the airline trade
association to two private plane
organizations and the controller's Union
god help us and trying to see if we can
get some kind of x in x them on it and
this project is under the auspices of
one of the major business organizations
in the united states that sees this as
critical to the future of business in
the United States to have air travel
that's not constrained by an obsolete
air traffic system and constrained
airspace that can't handle is enough
planes safely with the with the old
fashioned technology that they have so
if we can pull this off it could really
change the debate on this whole thing
because all that debate has been
characterized in the past by infighting
among the aviation groups and nobody
except the aviation groups inside the
beltway even knowing that the issue was
going on we're trying to change that in
a fundamental way by making it a cause
for the business community and trying to
have a unified coalition of all the
aviation groups or if many of them as
possible all singing out of the same hem
book and saying we got to do this so
that's what we're about will you'll see
as we start rolling this out whether we
get anywhere with it or not this year
thanks Bob excellent presentation I
wanted to go back to your Midway the
discussion of Chicago Midway Airport one
of the interesting aspects of that to
kind of link your talk and Adrienne's
talk before one of the interesting
aspects of that is my understanding and
you can confirm this that the deal with
that is if they are able to negotiate
that deal that after they pay off the
debt service and whatever you know the
the obligations are that of the
remaining proceeds I think it was under
state law 90
percent of those proceeds which would be
in the billions of dollars would have to
have to go to shore up public pension
funds the underfunded pensions in
Illinois which I find to be fascinating
because they made a direct link and
obviously there's many benefits there
but one of them is sort of creating that
wedge you know basically convincing the
public employee unions to back away from
their opposition to something like that
by saying well if we privatize this it's
going to work on to your it's going to
help your pension fund and then to
augment that you also brought up the
very valid point that a lot of the
investors a lot of the equity
behind-the-scenes that's going into the
whole public-private partnership
infrastructure world is coming from
public pension from public employee
pension funds I or any of that should
not be lost on anyone in this room the
public employee pension funds are
funding privatization projects
effectively now that's very good and so
to me take those two things together and
for me I've been telling policymakers a
lot now recently which is hey guys
privatized for the pensions privatized
for the pensions link them together
because if you want to smooth grease the
wheels for privatization well get the
pub way to get the public employee
unions to back off would be to help them
out in their underfunded pensions and so
I was wondering if you could you know
maybe what's your take on that what do
you do you think that's a valid viable
strategy and was mayor daley on to
something i think that is a very viable
strategy it's actually it's a it's a
smaller scale illustration of what is
going on today in Europe particularly
places like Spain and Greece that are
just under the gun in terms of bond
obligations that they can't pay for they
are in the process of doing large-scale
privatization programs with the proceeds
from those going to reduce their
indebtedness in exactly that kind of a
way so I mean Chicago doesn't have quite
the same magnitude of problems of Greece
or Spain but it's the same principle and
yeah it's a very good idea okay we have
time for one last question now to
curiosity with when you're dealing with
the unions is it possible to offer them
some kind of severance buyout so and if
it involves a reduction of employees and
at some point you can
we buy them out and maybe got to yell
bo-gyung good that's that's clearly the
idea we have involved in mind with air
traffic control is to figure out what
sort of combination of early retirement
sort of things no layoffs guarantees for
certain categories people with a certain
number of years left to go and things
like that and you know the rate of
change it's going to take a decade or
more to implement all of the different
modernization types of things and as a
there's already there's a pig in the
Python phenomenon of a lot of the
controllers that were hired after the
strike in the in the United es are
getting close to mandatory retirement
ages so that big bulge of people it's
not going to be a problem for too much
longer so there's deals that could be
made and and very possibly will be made
but so that but it's also that also
suggests though there's a real urgency
of trying to do this while you have a
manageable problem with the employees if
you get all those people retired and
then do the reform then you've got this
whole new workforce that's expecting to
have a 35-year career in aircraft
control that's going to be a much bigger
problem to deal with
you